what is happening reject nation it's
Greg Alba over here is John Humphrey
over here we're gonna watch the trailer
today for a Denzel film directed by Dan
Gilroy
good night crawler Roman J Israel
Esquire ask why don't just say Esquire
why does everything have to be cool and
abbreviated because it's alright I just
called for their Mahr ji Esquire rji
Esquire that sounds much actually sound
like a like a startup firm due to a
marriage was told he was not under
arrest yet he was refused used to the
bathroom that's violation of civil
rights you can address the truck I would
like to address it now I'm just saying
mr. Israel if guards in this courtroom
would not allow you to use the bathroom
you would by all definition be detained
over the whole tree of contempt if you
continue to pursue this you're asking me
to obey this court decision you tell me
to wait in my experience for you okay
[Music]
it's an enema of sunshine taking a
nanosecond off of your assembly line
rubber-stamp existence about what to
expect that you are arrested I'm gonna
rap I don't mean hip-hop I'm sorry by
the sister standing in her brother's
City a standard in sexist
and polite and patronizing and polite
for the Ducks for years you're inspiring
I'm tired of doing the impossible for
the ungrateful take care of yourself I
am nowhere cj's hold up stepworth
don't tell no by everything we discuss
will be confidential
[Music]
wonderful things and just heard
something about you from a solid source
you do where I was
that's you any time I walk these are
dangerous people
[Music]
better call Saul man
[Music]
I could finish this
he's one of us is greater than the worst
thing we've ever done they could have
called this American attorney I'm
married American made or lord of war or
wolf of wallstreet
this looks a little bit unexpected after
what you see like what Nightcrawler is
which certainly doesn't look as CD as
night no no no no no not at all I like
the approach of it of this guy he's not
exactly like the nicest guy to begin
with he intends to do good I like that
line he says like I'm sick of trying to
do the impossible for being grateful and
I feel like that's that's a big theme in
a pivotal point for this for this
specific character Roman but as the
trailer is playing out I did like the
way it took a turn because I was
thinking that oh it's the story about a
guy who's trying to do good and the
world's treating him unfair but he's
gonna have an opportunity to make
something monumental inspiring but I'm
like oh no he's breaking bad right now
he's going all Jimmy he's going breaking
you better call Saul right now my first
thought was oh this is like denzel's
pursuit of happy oh yeah yeah because I
thought it was gonna go under more be
like inspirational tale but no it's more
about the corruption tale I do
appreciate opposite side of that when
the inspirational tale doesn't actually
work out this is what happens yeah
that's essentially why I'm drawn to this
idea it's got a definite rhythm and a
definite flavor even just off this
trailer that like it doesn't look like
the guy if you told me that this was the
guy who made Nightcrawler after I
watched it I would be surprised at the
same time it still got that sense of
rhythm
well the cinematography is completely
different than the cinematography is
honoring the way films in this era were
shot and I CLA yeah he loves the way man
he has a love for LA going from nasty
late at night la slaughter de la yeah
overworked la yeah
period L racism and sexism yeah yeah
yeah I feel like Denzel is perfectly
cast or something like this I can't
recall the last time I was like ten so
was miscast this does look like a
definite character performance sometimes
Denzel is more Denzel than other times
enemies always pretty much great but I
like when he goes in know what a carrot
what this trailer really communicates
strongly is that the plot is greatly
driven by the emotions of the characters
yeah something that Nightcrawler does so
well totally and it's it's a very
different world in a very different
character and now we're doing that with
this specific character I love that
about what Dan Gilroy seems to be pretty
consistent at is making a character
study film but also giving us an
incredibly intriguing plot yeah as well
you know something very engrossing but
it also like you said hinges on the
rhythm that comes naturally from its
lead characters yeah I wish we got a
little bit more of Colin Farrell because
Colin Farrell I feel is an amazing actor
yeah and I would love a better sense for
who he is and what he's doing in this
you get a little hints of Colin Farrell
like he looks like maybe that can like
the cutthroat lawyer but then there's
also the same raised like yo you're
gonna get in trouble so my base is this
guy like oh where what's going on in it
or is he against what's going on you
know he's gotta at least be aware of the
reality ya know I'm wondering what turn
that down Gil Road will have this
character go down because the
Nightcrawler that character because it's
hard start his own like you know small
independent law and start advertising on
TV maybe buy a couple billboards
represent a couple drug dealers who are
down on their luck and stuff changes
yeah I saw and here we go and I don't
think this is a true story
yeah I was wondering if otherwise a
trailer would slap that all over look
it's real yeah when you're watching
you're like is this a true story yeah
but I don't think it is I think it's a
completely fictional tale so I like his
approach and I like how he's he's not
playing it safe necessarily I'm gonna do
something very different in tone and
style a completely different world too
but it also is the world of you know
going darker and getting a little bit
consumed by greed yeah yeah the blood
runs hot and that Gil
Tony damn there's at least I think one
other Gilroy who gets around and then
they're all really intricate writers
within Canon Jonathan Ken and Jonathan
Gilroy who are the who's that there's a
Ken Nolan yeah you he wrote transformers
the last night oh good I don't know if
he's related to the other omitted him
technically yes but we don't like to
talk is not watching this trailer yeah
it's a November release if it's not an
action movie with Denzel it's going to
be an austere movie which looks like a
pretty groovy snappy Oscar movie yeah
yeah definitely
all right guys what do you think of the
trailer for Michael Clayton you know the
Gilroy guy wrote about that lawyer who
gets into trouble subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell for
dad John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram check out our patreon so
become a patron rejected a goodbye